there is a thirst for Freedom around the  world you know you're talking about Iran  we can talk about Italy there's a thirst  for Freedom popping up except here  except the land of the free what is  happening here where is the thirst for  Freedom here what I see in the United  States is the opposite what I see is a  spoiled privileged complacent population  and you know it's interesting you talk  about women's rights over there what  Vinnie was saying is true you're talking  about re this is what real  discrimination looks like thank you this  is active discrimination when you talk  about women's rights in the United  States right now you know what you talk  about allowing women to do late-term  abortions on babies so we who's lost  here we are we are lost we are a society  that we are supposed to be the land of  the free we are supposed to be what  other places look to and say we want to  do that what are we doing